our method for estimating sums can also
be used to estimate products basically
by taking logs to turn a product into a
sum and we're going to use that to come
up with another important estimate of a
quantity that will come up really very
regularly called n factorial so n
factorial is the product of the first n
integers 1 times 2 of little n minus 1
times n and concise product notation
it's the product that's PI capital ply
for product from I equals 1 to N of I
and it's standard abbreviation is to
write it as n bank pronounced n
factorial so what I'd like to do is get
an asymptotic estimate for n factorial
again n factorial is one of these
quantities where there isn't any exact
formula that doesn't have those ellipses
in it there's no short formula with
basic operations fixed size up formula
that expresses n factorial but we get a
nice formula for a tight asymptotic
estimate so as I said the first trick is
to turn the product into a sum by taking
logs so log of n factorial is the log of
1 the product of 1 through n but a log
of a product is the sum of the logs so
it's simply log of 1 plus log of 2 up
through log of n and expressed in some
notation it's the sum from I equals 1 to
N of log of log of a my now the integral
method gives us a way to estimate this
sum by bracketing it between the values
of some integrals namely restating the
the integral method for some metaphor
for bounding integrals by sums this time
we're looking at an increasing function
because it's log of X let F be a weakly
increasing function from positive reals
to positive reals I'm interested in the
sum from I equals 1 to N of F of I and I
want to relate it and bound it by the
integral from 0 from 1 to N of f of X
where in this case the particular F that
we're interested in is f of X is log X
and the theorem says that with
increasing functions S is bracketed
between the integral plus the
term in the sum and the integral plus
the first term in the sum remember since
the functions weakly increasing f of 1
is smaller than f of n so that's the way
you remember which way the bounds go so
s is between I plus F of 1 and I plus F
of n by our general formula for applying
integral balance to sums well what that
tells us then is that the sum from 1 to
N of log of I which is what we're
interested in is bracketed between the
integral from 1 to N of log X and the
integral from 1 to N well it's plus log
of 0 but a log of 1 rather but that's 0
and the integral from 1 to N of log of X
plus the last term which is log of n ok
in case you don't remember from first
term calculus the integral from of log
of X is in fact has the indefinite
integral is X log of x over E which you
can easily check by differentiating X
log X over e ln means natural log
remember in computer science l OG log
means log to the base 2 unless you
explicitly put some base on it like log
L o G sub 10 so ellen is the natural log
from calculus and plugging in this value
for the indefinite integral of log of X
and using the bounds 1/n what we come up
with is that the sum of the logs is
bounded between n Times log and over E
and n Times log and over e plus log of n
it's a pretty tight bounds what that
means is that informally speaking the
sum of the logs is about this term Plus
that term Plus let's take the average
value of that term which is half this
term so we could say that the sum of the
logs is approximately equal that's a
little vague but live with it n log n
over e plus a lot half of log n well now
if I'm interest to remember in an
estimate for n factorial so let's
exponentiate both sides so taking eita
this sum gives me a product of e to the
e to this times e to that well eat to
this
is really--it's e to the log of n over e
to the nth power which means it's n over
e to the N and this is e to the log of n
to the power half or square root of n so
we wind up with n factorial is
approximately equal to the square root
of n times n over e to the N now this
approximately equal is imprecise it's
not asymptotically equal because we were
doing an arithmetic average of zero and
log n over two in addition it's very
dangerous when you have two things that
are approximately equal to exponentiate
them and expect that they're still
approximately equal often they aren't
but nevertheless this is a kind of a
heuristic derivation of some kind of
asymptotic estimate that we would expect
that n factorial was roughly like the
square root of n times n over e to the
enth power and it turns out that it's
that this heuristic gives a pretty
accurate answer a precise approximation
is that n factorial is actually
asymptotically equal to the square root
of 2 pi n times n over e to the end and
we're not going to prove that it
requires elementary calculus but more
than we want to take time for and this
crucial formula though that we will be
using very regularly to estimate the
size of n factorial is called Sterling's
formula and it's one to have on your
crib sheets if you haven't memorized it